do you remember the first script that
you pitched
i i
probably well i said i made short films
forever so i made a whole bunch of short
films to begin with and all of those
were like i i that was in the old days
of super 8 where basically it cost money
and i would come up with whatever the
cool short film idea was grab my friends
and go out and make it the very first
film i shot
was actually on regular eight before
super 8 was even invented probably or
maybe at least before i could afford the
camera was called laundromat and it was
a comedy about a single guy
away from home for the first time out
you know in college doing his first load
of laundry and not knowing anything
and uh you know his shoes he launders
puts his shoes in the laundromat washing
machine
do you remember the first time you
actually pitched to a studio executive
or something well i
i don't know i'm fuzzy on that um
because what happened is i i sold a spec
script and this to a company on the
paramount lot
and
that
i was sort of so focused on doing the
rewrites on that that i was stupid and
didn't
pitch anything and didn't didn't sort of
ride the coattails of that deal
because i was not smart enough to do
that at the time um
later on and the next two things i sold
were spec scripts and again i didn't
actually pitch any you know anything to
him it probably came to
you know some place i know what it was
oh it was weird it was a strange
situation
um and this may not be the actual first
but it's i'm going to claim it uh
i had a meeting with a producer who had
a
uh an action male action star and needed
a vehicle for them for the action star
and wanted it to be like terminator and
i said you know i think i got a better
idea than this and pitch them a
different idea
but that that was like the first time i
ever pitched anything that went from
there i i pitched them virtual reality
because i just
the weekend before um showbiz expo uh
had been or actually a couple of
weekends before showbiz expo had been in
the convention center in los angeles and
a friend of mine and i had gone through
all the stuff and as we were leaving um
there was in the parking lot a roller
coaster being assembled
and my friend jim said
what's the roller coaster gonna what's
what's happening next week here we went
in and talked to the management of the
uh la um
convention center they go oh we're we
have the uh
whatever it is uh the
theme park
uh convention going on here so jim and i
snuck into the theme park convention and
rode roller coasters ate corn dogs drank
beer did all that stuff for free but
also
tried the na the newest thing in theme
parks which was virtual reality rides
and so
nobody really knew about virtual reality
rides except
you know jim and i had done this it was
cutting edge stuff and i thought that's
a story so when the producer wanted to
do a terminator rip off i said what if
we do a virtual reality movie instead i
think that'd be cool the audience hasn't
seen it and the producer went virtual
reality what's that and i saw i had to
explain it to him and say by the time
this film comes out everyone will know
what it means
so if you were to groom another
screenwriter who's going in to pitch
their idea what are some
quick and dirty little tips you could
tell them the first thing is is that
it's it's all about the concept um when
you pitch something uh there's a thing
they call the elevator pitch and that's
pretty much how you're going to pitch
something no matter whether you're in an
elevator or whether you're in a pitch
session like someplace here and what you
want to do is not tell the whole story
you just want to tell the idea of the
story um i just got back from the
portland film festival and i was on a
pitch panel there and one of the
other people in the pitch panel said
which you never want to say in your
pitches and then
because what that is is you're just
telling scene by scene by scene they
don't care about that that's what that's
what reading the scripts for what you
want to do is interest them enough so
that they ask to read the script which
means you come up with a great concept
that that makes them go i want to see
this movie i want to read this script
and once you come up with that great
concept
you might pitch
five sentences and that's it
and if they like the five if they you
can sum the idea up in like five
sentences
then after that they might ask you
questions well what if you know what
happens when this happens and then you
go then you can tell more of the details
but if you start out with the guy wakes
up and he combs his hair and he does
this it's the most boring pitch in the
world what we want to do is is like
focus on the meat it's a story about a
very uptight fbi agent who's everything
by the book crew cut hair
and hates the new young fbi agent guys
and basically
because he doesn't fit into the new fbi
model they transfer him to the division
of the fbi that deals with crime on
nudist colonies across the united states
and now
this guy who's used to wearing a suit
and tie wears nothing he's got a badge
he's got a gun you don't want you don't
know where he keeps the badge and he's
part of the nude fbi
that's my fake pitch
i would pay 12 dollars see that's you
know that the whole idea
that that came from there was the the
fbi show on abc and when they brought it
back it was the new fbi and i thought
wouldn't it be funny if it was the nude
fbi because fbi guys are always so
uptight if i you know i want to see that
the naked guys in car chases and
shootouts and fist fights
you